This looks better, but it won't work yet. First, you'll need to implement
getLowScorePosition. Implement it so that it only looks through the data once.
And remembers the position of the low score, as well as the score itself. To
implement getLowScoreIndex, we'll follow the algorithim we talked about
earlier, for finding the first portrait in the picture gallery. But this time,
we're using it on a partially filled array, instead of an ArrayList. So we have
to be more careful. We'll start by assuming that the lowest score, is the first
one. Then we'll look at all of the items, starting at one, because we already
looked at zero. Now for each of those elemlents, we'll compare it to the lowest
score, and if it's smaller, we changed what we think the lowest score is. Now,
while we're looking for the lowest score, we also need to look for its index.
So, initially we assumed that the lowest score index was zero, and when we find
a lower score, we'll update the lowest score index to be the index of that
score. Now, when we finish looking at everything, the lowest score index that
we found so far will be the overall lowest score index. Now that I have this
method, the simpler version of removing the minimum score will work. I'll test
it so I can be sure. And it looks like it correctly dropped one of the fives.